I'm very big and I play tallien in
shadow of Mordor my name is Christian
Kenta Meza and I am the cool writer and
director of shadow but we just met we
had lunch and it was pretty instant
we're like okay both of us that they
were like this is the guy this is the
guy this is somebody that I trust with
this the relationship just evolved or
the material and over the way we managed
to kind of bring the pages along with
him
shadow of Mordor is I would say a new
chapter in universe of the world that
Tolkien has created and it's kind of
arranging a gap between the story of The
Hobbit and the story of the Lord of the
Rings four-foot shadow of Mordor the
challenge was to create something new
but there was built on the foundation of
Tolkien and to be respectful of his
ideas while incorporating ours and to be
respectful of the fans and the scholars
that have studied the material and at
the same time allow us to apply the
material to video game media we've had
some incredible moments creating some
incredible scenes they're emotionally
driven they're impactful there's not one
scene in this game that is superfluous
everything is incredibly purposeful and
if it wasn't got cut the little I could
do to help draw it was really just have
a conversation and ask some questions to
see if I could get the answers that
could move the story forward in a filmic
way which is my job and stimulate his
creativity to bring a character alive
and I think we created an environment on
the set where everybody was also allowed
to help each other yeah and when they
stepped on the stage they where the
characters and at that point my job was
to just get out of the way
see for yourself